non è successo niente no non è vero
scherzavo non si apre lo sapevo mica
gigantesco porca vacca non sapevo che
c'era non lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
prova già anche capito cosa devo fare mi
sa devo andare qua devo prendere la
corda nel barile
e poi c'erano nella stanza non mi
ricordo quale dove gli parlavano di
raccordare il barile quindi devo
riportare la corda indietro nuovo che
parte non so dove però stai verbo to c'è
qualcuno invisibile non parlare per
favore per cortesia corda dalla corda a
mi stai dando questa corda giudizio
lavora di modi di dire cieli ti do una
mano ti do corda insegnando questa corda
dai la corda ebbene grazie prendi questo
punto libro della morte grazie molto
silvio gentile simpatica solare libero
della notte
il raduno ferro e ruggine sta dall'altra
parte però zio libro d'amore di libro
della morte leggi
forse non dovevo leggerlo mi sa che noi
non dovevo o non dovevo leggerlo madonna
ma che brutta roba ma io non dormo
stanotte c'era lo spazio della libreria
che pirla di prelà morte leggina non
leggere metti libro sullo scaffale
perfetto hai messo libro nella libreria
bene hai sentito il coperto linate che
finalmente mori e morgan maremma roux
carmen è un po unito due dialetti prove
[Musica]
nola possa prendere ok non potevo
prendere la farfalla vabbè possono
rientrare effetto o ha tenuto il
modellino di farfalla bene va via via
via a buongiorno è andato a prendere il
caffè al bar posto
ok adesso la farfalla quindi posso
sostituire questa con l'altra farfalla
con la navetta prendi ok ma dellino di
farfalla veit hai attaccato il modellino
di farfalla alla ragnatela perfetto
sotto ma indietro ma che è la farfalla
svolazza via dalle tue mani l'ass
e se la svigna attraverso il muro senti
qualcosa sbloccarsi da qualche parte va
bene il gatto
se mai fosse passato davanti al
cavaliere mi sarei preso le mazzate
porti che farina sono sacchi di farina
question salve gatto nero io bella fra
minchia come ci spacchiamo siamo tutti
ibridi
la gang felina non si fa ma il muro è
macchiato di rosso e appiccicoso e
sangue
si chiama sangue quello lo dico io
[Musica]
questi questo si chiama vere sfiga però
io sono tutto ninja a descriverne altri
questa non me l'aspettavo 10pro vado a
culo
ok non me l'hanno tirato più perfetto a
posto vai vai via via via di qui vieni
qua gatto a gatto cercato di olio
comunque questa è la casa di una strega
grazie grazie a oggetti grazie vinchiana
se non ci fossi tu guarda se non ci
fossi tu proprio non saprei proprio che
pesci prendere anziché gatti prendere ti
piacciono le rane non mi piacciono i
treni che la fame rana ma che tesoro ha
messo il cuoricino ma non so più single
a rana ti sta seguendo una rana smarrita
che cerca la sua casa amore dai ho
trovato la ragazza è il mio principe
azzurro lei si trasforma in pietro
troviamo un posto sta bella donna
un ponte molto sottile dai un'occhiata
ispezionato dai un'occhiata riesce a
vedere una specie di leva discrezione il
ponte e vi sottile la tua gamba si
romperebbe in qualsiasi momento sotto il
tuo peso mandarà rara ma dalla rara
nuova lettera porca eva sacchi caritas t
ok fi tra salerano vai vai tesoro mai
amore mio della mia vita vai sentivo
cosa sbloccarsi tesoro grazie ok
perfetto amore mio inseparabili io e te
gattoni che minchia ti sembrava la
strega quella dai la tua conferma così
ne sono sicuro no niente faccio salvare
aveva beccato una porta si è aperta crea
un'immagine speculare al che ho capito
devo spingere le cose è chiaro chiaro
poi c'è la rana qua una rari sbagliata è
fissata la sedia apre benedetto laureto
qua giustamente perfetto che pirla che
sono mica anch'io
a che serve a moderare esattamente lo
facevo anche con sulla settimana
enigmistica quando ero piccolo contro ai
difetti grande quando sul muro c'è un
interruttore sulla cornice premi
perfetto si stacco al forum a tua madre
morta e strappato al foglio per stanza
senza adesso sono speculari o mi
chiamava ormai di far tornare i ragazzi
che allora la poverina lascia da qua
scusa tesoro ha visto di via ero
incazzato perdonami avevo cibo lo porta
si aperta bene anche un'altra storia
attraverso la prossima porta e non
lasciare che qualcosa di strano che
senso
il padre mio padre mi vedano come così
li ho
hicks sono rimasti in questa casa da
allora dunque lo attraversa la porta e
non lasciare che nulla mi distraggo
[Musica]
ok però bisogno di salvare la partita ha
fame ha fame chi è che ha fame a terni
c'è qualcosa dall'altra parte e pietro
che dall'altra parte scusa guarda la
porta ascolta attentamente aprì la porta
non fare niente
senti qualcosa di grosso strisciare c'è
una finestrella grande quanto la tua
mano davvero è che devi falso qua o
fissarla tutto il giorno
apri era meglio fissarla tutto il giorno
apri la porta davvero no non fare niente
faccio niente siamo qua giochiamo un
altro gioco ha fame che cosa vuoi la
vita mia ma io questa roba non ricordavo
no ho trovato un'altra rana ti devo
frenare mi dispiace no mi chiami
dispiace tantissimo ma se va a far la
run è riluttante papaverina no no va beh
non posso ma sta roba persona ma
impastati gatto che mi sa in culo
una larga fessura attualmente bagnato è
pozza di sangue
bene grazie alla shell all aran e dietro
è lo spirito che mi perseguita ti calmi
gatti fatemi salvare per vi prego sotto
forma di gatto
si è mossa tra l'altro ciao gatto una
sotto forma di gatto non è vero
scherzavo simpaticissimo di giorni puoi
fare lo youtube ei gay non ignorarmi
guarda ti ignorerei moltissimo se non
fosse che devo salvare la partita quindi
però devi stare calmo pensi che la testa
si sia mossa si che lo penso l'ho visto
sono mica scemo vai dove solo un occhio
è aperto ma c'è un problema di fondo qua
non ci sono gli occhi singoli aperti
provò a caso non era questo è bene era
questo porca vacca ho trovato un
passaggio è figura
no non me lo ricordavo mai stato
l'occhio mi fissava mentre entravo
fantastico bene gli hudson ice fai un
solo in quattro stanze che senso salve
un soldato giocatore con un'arma finta
se figure si è finta quella roba lì fai
un suono in quattro stanze cosa vuol
dire fai un suono in quattro stanze
scusa un piccolo taliano nokia vino
[Musica]
una scatoletta non si apre chiarirà
strega leggi o ips tutti gli amici che
sono venuti a casa mia dopo quello sono
stati tutti i mangiati dalla casa mazza
o amici e pc finiti male come sia tolta
non si apre va bene che bella sta musica
mi piace un sacco ma perché o non vale
carmela finta e comunque va bene va bene
occhi blu vedono lo spartito o la
monnalisa tinta o la monna lisa
rorschach un quadro di una donna dai
capelli rossi suo sguardo si parlerà di
stanza meno male che non era quella
originale sono era un casino ma la porta
di saper chiusa immagine ma non l'ha
richiusa
ok non hai bisogno di suonare
no anche perché non sono capace quindi
nega un libro intitolato studi sugli
occhi leggi le persone hanno occhi di
diversi colori gioco istruttivo quest
conosciamo quanto segue sulle donne in
questa regione in particolare il colore
degli occhi una donna dipende dai suoi
capelli
i quattro cori dei capelli sono argento
nero oro e rosso quattro cori degli
occhi sono marrone verde blu e rosso è
le donne che capelli argentati hanno gli
occhi rossi quella bionda e rossa la
togliamo quindi biondo rosso argentato
togliamo biondo rosso argentato via
quello che rimane è quella che gli occhi
blu biondo andato giù rosso argentato
via questa agli occhi blu quadro di una
donna coi capelli neri su quando si
parlerà di stanza è ma che vuoi la vita
mia scusa a devo guardare dove sta
guardando
mammamia genio prendi me la ricordavo
mai figurati e ha ottenuto uno spartito
musicale bene
porca vacca la monna lisa normale che ho
salvato sono stato previdente presidente
degli stati uniti come faccio per i
nasseriani ok
vai prendi come lo giro scusa cavalca la
vanga aiuto ecco la passa su insiste i
tavoli sui divani e zucchero maron e
ansia nel quadro in quadro strappa via
eccolo all'ultimo secondo il quadro
spiegazzate distorto la donna è sparita
dal dipinto minchia meno male ok
sì però dovete stare tutti calmi viper
ti prego non è che non c'era un effetto
sonoro emidio malissimo
ce lo spartito però non so suonare però
c'è una porta 4 cercata figura c'è una
piccola scritta sulla porta fai un solo
in quattro stanze ho capito un attimo
sedi e non ridete mentre suono è che già
ho avuto esperienze brut suona
quindi ragazzi anche per oggi si
conclude qui il primo ep secondo
episodio di the witch hunt però capito
vi sia piaciuto andiamo poi con il terzo
che sarà una bomba questo gioco più
avanti meglio è però sicuro ne mancano
ancora due di episodi è una bomba
mi piace un botto spero vi piace anche a
voi spero che bisogna starci roma 16 ago
il suo genere nel senso che vi siete non
ci vediamo bene
[Musica]
ma